قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده على استعداد لاتفاق على حلول مقبوله
مع جميع الشركاء لتسويه النزاع في
اوكرانيا
برفض الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات اضافه في
مقابله تلفزيونيه ان من وصفهم بخصوم روسيا
كانوا وما يزالون يسعون لتفكيك بلاده
للقضايا الاشكاليه سلميه عبر التفاوض
للاسف الجانب الاخر كان لديه نهج مختلف اذ
بدا باتخاذ خطوات صارمه وتنفيذ عمليات
العسكريه
لحمايه الناس الذين يقتلون تلك الاراضي
لسنا نحن من قام بتنفيذ الانقلاب في
اوكرانيا وجوهره كل ما يحدث هو سياسته من
الجيو سياسيه التي تهدف الى تفكير روسيا
عبر التاريخ هدفنا توحيد الشعب الروسي
نعمل في الاتجاه الصحيح لنحميه مصالحنا
ومصالحنا ولا يوجد لدينا خيار اخر